recent financial scandals like Lux leaks
and the Panama papers brought to light
murky financial practices in Europe and
Beyond in the wake of those revelations
Parliament set up a special committee to
investigate how to tackle financial
crimes tax evasion and tax avoidance the
committee has wrapped up its year-long
investigation the financial sector
itself the banks they are not fulfilling
the obligations to stop finance of
crimes and money-laundering taking place
via their banks and the consequences
when you have facilitating pairs of
crimes or tax crimes are very limited
while Europe has taken significant steps
to increase tax transparency following
the scandals the committee says more
needs to be done better coordination is
needed between Member States financial
authorities and failing that Europe
needs to be able to enforce tougher
rules itself we all agree that we must
work on enforcement and enforcement is
linked to better cooperation between the
institutional if cooperation is not
enough and we are not able to move
forward we must consider creation of new
body those new bodies could include an
EU anti-money laundering watchdog to aid
coordination between national tax
authorities and a European financial
police force to enforce cross-border
rules other recommendations include
phasing out so-called golden visas or
passports for investment schemes which
undermine the fight for fairness and
transparency and better protection for
whistleblowers who alert authorities to
crimes and malpractice
you